[Music]
I caught it, my
father and my mother. I
want to eat it all by myself someday.
Wait, I'm still mentally prepared. Our
oldest memory is the room with the daphnia-patterned wallpaper.
If we go there, we'll know something about the
house in this village.  Let's be
friends, Hitori-kun. It's the
first time I've ever said
something like this to someone.
[Music]
Come to think of it, you're
from an institution.
[Music] I
want to believe you, Hitori-kun. I
see,
yours.  My mind is distorted. Don't let your
guard down. I'm totally aware of this. Let's
proceed with caution.
[Music] I've
been waiting for this day for a long time.
Polygon Village. What a
person without a master?
[Music]
My mother became a person from Polygon Village.  He was killed.